they're going back to the poles here you
guys voting today hello
these are midterm elections when America
decides who will hold power in National
and state politics hi good morning in
two years time the presidential vote
will come around again so it seems
of a familiar face
more than before Donald Trump is teasing
a presidential run in 2024
in order to make our country successful
and safe and glorious
I will very very very probably do it
again okay
the Republican party has been reshaped
in Donald Trump's Shadow its members
feel his gravitational pull
action denials like Marjorie Taylor
Greene who shared a stage in Iowa and
party policy on Ukraine if it wins the
power on Tuesday
Republicans not another Penny will go to
Ukraine
[Applause]
of course an effort to get back into
this place might not be the only thing
on Donald Trump's Horizon that our
ongoing criminal investigations into the
assault on the capital and the discovery
of classified government documents at
his mar-a-laga Resort in Florida his
opponents already point out that a
presidential run will offer him a shield
of sorts that if he's indicted he'll
claim it's politically motivated
opinion polls suggest the midterms will
give the Republicans a good night on
Tuesday it would give a trump
announcement a boost Donald Trump good
or bad for your party your country
he's very good for our party and he's
very good for our country why
he's very successful he's a proven
executive he knows how to do things I
don't think he did a good job when he
was in office I haven't been feeling
very confident in the things that have
happened after his presidency
so I just don't think that would be a
good idea for him to do that he doesn't
do anything that brings people together
he's divisive and that's problematic
confirmation of a third run in the white
house will be no surprise it will be the
comeback of the man who never really
went away neither did the turbulence of
his one term in office
James Matthews Sky News in Washington